- Here we are in the
Hoh Valley Rainforest.
This is a cathedral, my cathedral.
In this forest is the quietest place
in the entire United States,
and it's only one square inch in size.
My mission is to keep it that way.
I'm Gordon Hempton.
I'm a sound tracker.
I travel the globe in
search of vanishing sounds,
including the most endangered of all,
which is simply silence.
Noise pollution is nearly inescapable.
The Hoh Valley is the quietest,
least noise-polluted place
in the entire lower 48.
I don't know if I can save silence,
but I know that I can try.
So it was 12 years ago, 2005 Earth Day,
that I hiked up the Hoh River Valley.
It took three miles just to escape
the noise of the parking lot.
That's when I was looking
in every direction
for which way I should go.
I saw the elk trail, love
to follow their advice
because they love quiet just like I do;
and they led me right to the spot.
It's just through that tree,
then off into the woods.
I defend this one square inch of silence
by doing both quiet and noise monitoring.
When a noise intrusion occurs,
I locate the noise maker,
send them a letter,
and ask for compliance.
This matter is urgent.
Within ten years, it's
likely that there will be
no quiet places left
unless we take action.
When I first started, I did not think
silence would go extinct in my lifetime;
and if that happens,
the quiet will disappear
and the wildlife will be devastated.
The One Square Inch of Silence foundation
is pressing our politicians
to pass a single piece
of legislation that will
designate Olympic National Park
as the world's first quiet
park, off-limits to aircraft.
All things are possible.
The Earth is here and it's beautiful;
and, for me, it all starts
here in the Hoh Valley.